[Music]
on holocaust memorial day
we remember the six million jews who
were murdered by the nazis
and all victims of nazi persecution
including roma
gay and disabled people the holocaust
threatened the fabric of civilization
and the world said never again
but genocides have continued to take
place across the world
in cambodia from 1975 to 79
in rwanda in 1994
in bosnia in 1995
and in darfur since 2003
genocide doesn't just happen
it starts with divisive language and
people being targeted because of their
identity
during and after genocide the
experiences of those who were persecuted
are denied
[Music]
we cannot be complacent prejudice must
be challenged by us all
on holocaust memorial day people come
together in workplaces
local councils schools and communities
to learn from genocide and create a
better future hi
and welcome from saint michael's church
here in
raleigh it's my privilege and to
just lead us in a holocaust memorial
service
normally we would be gathered outside
the
mill hall center but of course in these
strange and unusual times
it's not safe and appropriate to do so
but it's good that we can still set
aside this moment to pause
to remember the atrocities of the past
that we might learn from those things
be transformed in our own lives and set
aside
just this moment to make a difference
and to remember well so this online
service will have
multiple contributors and it's my
privilege
to simply lead our service and do
our prayers so we gather to
remember what many of us have never
experienced or seen
but we have heard that millions were
torn from home
removed from all that was familiar
and relocated with an orchestrated
cruelty
that stretches the mind we have seen the
evidence
we have heard the witness today
we remember and shall and shall share
the silence
of remembering together
we who dwell in security cannot imagine
the horror of being
uprooted in uncertainty
we who enjoy comfort cannot comprehend
the depths of pain we
who seek to know still struggle to
understand
how it came to be that humanity
could become so inhuman
millions of jews and others were torn
from their home
uprooted but they will not be torn
from our memory today
they have a home in the silence of our
shared
remembering so let us just hold
a moment of silence and then we'll pray
so may we pray heavenly father
whose many gifts include memory
and empathy we hold in remembrance
before you
those many of the jewish people who were
murdered
harmed or displaced in the horror of
nazi persecution and whose communities
were destroyed
in your mercy help us to learn to accept
our differences without fear
and cleanse our hearts of all hatred
so may every human community flourish
and every home be secure to the
advancements
of your loving purposes and the glory
of your name amen
27th of january is holocaust memorial
day
holocaust memorial day is a day each
year when we remember the 6 million
jewish people
who were systematically persecuted and
murdered by the nazis
and their collaborators during the
holocaust
it is a day for everyone to remember the
millions of people killed in the
holocaust
nazi persecution and his subsequent
genocides in cambodia
rwanda bosnia and r4
on holocaust memorial day we honour the
survivors of these regimes of hatred and
challenge ourselves to use the lessons
of their experience to inform our lives
today the theme for holocaust memorial
day 2021
is be the light in the darkness
it is an affirmation and a call to
action for everyone marking
holocaust memorial day increasing levels
of denial division and misinformation in
today's world
mean we must remain vigilant against
hatred and identity
based hostility we can all stand in
solidarity
we can choose to be the light in the
darkness in a variety of ways and places
at home in public and online
genocide does not happen out of the blue
it is a result of prejudice
and persecution which sees a group
treated differently from the rest of
society
on holocaust memorial day we're reminded
of what can happen when prejudice and
persecution are left unchallenged
now their responsibility is to stand
against these processes
when we see them in our own communities
everyone can take some action to support
others
by using our voices presence platform
or influence
thank you councillor grey may we now
pray oh god for those of us who haven't
experienced it we cannot really
imagine what it is like to go through
such an atrocity
as a holocaust or other genocides
but may jesus manifesto
to proclaim release to their captives
and let the oppressed go free
be our manifesto
help us to be alert to the insidious
creep
of the type of propaganda that led to
jewish people and other victims of
genocide
being seen as subhuman dispensable
help us overcome any fear and apathy
and grant us the courage to speak and
act
in the face of evil
help us to imagine the world as you
would have it to be
and to strive for it no matter how
impossible that might
appear help us to
truly be the body of christ
living in tune with your will for the
whole of humanity
in his name we pray amen
we now have a poem
ellie wiesel was born in 1928 in
sickhead transylvania
which is now part of romania
he was 15 when he and his family were
deported
by the nazis to auschwitz this poem
is from the memoir he wrote about his
experience
never shall i forget that night
the first night in camp that turned my
life into one
long night seven times sealed
never shall i forget that smoke never
shall i forget the small faces
of the children whose bodies i saw
transformed into smoke
under a silent sky never shall i forget
those flames that consumed my faith
forever never shall i forget the
nocturnal silence
that deprived me for all eternity of the
desire
to live never shall i forget those
moments that murdered my god
and my soul and turned my dreams to
ashes
never shall i forget those things even
if i were condemned to live
as long as god himself
never next
we will hear an interview with holocaust
survivor dr martin
stern dr martin stern mbe
was five years old when he was taken to
a concentration camp
in this film martin is asked questions
about his experiences by members
of the hmdt youth programs and hmd
youth board
we asked members of the hmdt youth
programmes and hmd youth board
to ask questions to dr martin stern mbe
the survivor of the holocaust about
his experiences martin was born in 1938
in the netherlands his parents were
german but fled to the netherlands in
part because nazi laws forbade his
non-jewish mother
for marrying his jewish father at the
age of five
i was arrested at school
two young men came in and asked is
martin stern here
and the teacher tried to deny i was
there
but i didn't know what was going on
people had been careful not to tell me
what they thought about the nazis in
case i repeated it
with fatal consequences for them
and i put my hand up and gave myself
away
and as i was being
taken out of that little school hall
i looked round and i'll never forget the
ashen face of the teacher
my sister aged one year old was
arrested by dutch police about the same
time
we ended up in a prison camp in the
netherlands
creosote wooden huts bare soil big
barbed wire fence
watch towers and i was told not to go
anywhere near that
fence because the soldiers in the
watchtowers would shoot you
dead the food was terrible for
vegetables you'd been and not a lot of
those
and every week a train of goods trucks
and cattle trucks taking
people away in a crammed full
and i watched these trucks being loaded
up
eventually of course my turn came
most of those trucks had a sign on the
side saying
that they were going either to auschwitz
or sobibor the names were on the side of
the trains
people didn't know what those names
meant
but my train
was a similar train but it went to a
different place
otherwise i wouldn't be here cutting was
taken from western port transit camp
to the there's the extent of
concentration camp north of prague
on arrival i was removed from the other
children
by a dutch woman prisoner who wanted to
look after a couple of kids somebody had
told her
that there were two children on this
train from the netherlands
whose father had killed two german
soldiers
and so she picked us and she looked
after us in whichever women's dormitory
she was in it changed all the time
she stole food for us she did other
things which were risking her life
it was highly irregular what she was
doing
eventually it was announced that
children had to board the next train
now we weren't hidden she couldn't keep
us off that train
but believing that we would be going to
our deaths
and it would mean her death too she
went with us to the assembly place
to get on that train she couldn't bear
to let us go alone
and our names weren't called
the other children were killed in
auschwitz
my guess is that the list that was read
out
was the list of children in the
children's building that by taking us
from amongst the other children
she had saved our lives
the nazis lost we eventually
ended up in the netherlands and were
taken away from this wonderful
woman who had risked her life for us
repeatedly
and my sister and i made lives in the
netherlands and then as children
in 1950 were moved to britain
to manchester and i went to school and
university trained as a doctor
became a hospital specialist in
leicester
had a wife three children seven
grandchildren
and here i am
why do you think it is important to
share your story and for people to know
about the holocaust
an amazing proportion of the population
really do not know about the holocaust
and of course there are people who deny
that it happened or deny that it was
anything like as bad as
people claim or claim that the jews
engineered it for ulterior motives
horrific libels against
the jews of the world
i realized late in my career having
really not
talked about it for
since a very short time after coming
back from
this prison town that
if i didn't talk about it nobody would
know
if you could see the teacher who tried
to save your life
what would you say to her she will be an
extremely old lady now if she's still
alive
if i met her i think i would want to
embrace her and weep
[Music]
how difficult was it for you to move to
a new country at such a young age
it was difficult it is difficult
changing from one country to another
especially without your parents and of
course my sister and i were not the only
children subjected to that
from the age of three to the age of
seven i had practically no contact with
other children
you know if you deliberately did that to
a child
in this country now you would be
rightly accused of maltreating that
child abusing it
that itself has an influence it is also
even between two very similar countries
like the netherlands and britain
a cultural difference the way you're
expected
to behave is uh subtly
but in important ways different
and there's some in some ways i still
haven't
uh fully acclimatized to britain
although my
i feel more and more british as i get
older
but at the same time there are benefits
from moving to another country
it's a wonderful thing to become
bilingual even if it's a
hard and in my case it was an unpleasant
process but it seems to have worked more
or less
and um by knowing two languages you
learn to
appreciate your original language and
the beauty of language it's a
joy being bilingual and it protects you
against
dementia i'm told
at the same time i think all young
people should if they possibly can
spend some time living and working in
another country
and experiencing culture shock it's
very good for you it has benefits it you
learn to understand your own culture for
a start
so yes there are disadvantages
it pales into insignificance compared to
what happened during the war
of course but there are benefits and
i'm so proud to be british in a guardian
article
you said that surviving is like undoing
a combination block by chance
what did you mean by this what i meant
by that
is that the nazi system was very
efficient
they were using the bureaucracy of a
state
and the bureaucracy tradition
of the prussian army
and and the prussian state that flowed
from it
uh it was very hard to escape the
nazi net uh at least uh
once they had caught you once they they
if you were not hidden from them and
even then
i think all the survivors i know
had something going wrong with that
efficient system
in my own case if a dutch couple had not
looked after me for two years
in amsterdam keeping me out of the
clutches of the nazis
i would not have survived most holocaust
survivors were caught
late it was one of the secrets of
survival
if i had been sent to auschwitz or
sobibor like most of the children
in the prison camp i would not have
survived
i would have gone straight to the gas
chambers
if in the prison town terresian start
i had not been taken out from the other
children
my name would have been read out to
board that
train to our shirts if that woman who
was looking after my sister and i
had not told me fiercely to
not go and see a doctor
a prisoner doctor or nurse when i was as
yellow as a lemon
and peeing pee the color of black coffee
and feeling awful
she told me to keep out of view or i
would be killed
again that would have been the end of me
she thought and i think she had good
reason
if my father had not shot dead
two of his pursuers when he was being
captured
then that woman would not have picked my
sister and i
so one piece of good fortune was nowhere
near enough
you had to have bizarre strange
pieces of good fortune one after the
other after the other
without that you would not survive
that's what i meant by being like
unlocking
a combination lock how did you maintain
hope during the holocaust
firstly i'm not sure that i did keep
hope
people have asked me how i felt as a
child
in teresenstart in the prison town
and i find it very hard to describe i'm
not sure that my memory is that
perfect for it but i think the best
description frankly would be depression
it would be the sort of nearest
word i can find to the way i can
remember feeling
i had almost no contact with other
children
not much contact with adults because the
women i was amongst were all doing slave
labor during the daytime
it was a lonely scary
existence and of course i saw people
being packed off and i
saw the fear that people had
at the thought of being packed off on
one of the trains
so i'm not sure that i did have
a lot of hope i i think i did have a
kind of optimism
but it's hard to describe and and
[Music]
it was certainly limited
[Music]
do you feel anger towards the nazis
of course i feel anger at the actions
i refuse to let
my mind be occupied by anger
at these very stupid
people who did evil things
because that only harms me
have you ever returned to the
netherlands if so how did it make you
feel
i go to the netherlands quite often and
i maintain my contacts
with some very good friends in the
netherlands
and i like being in the netherlands uh
even though by now i feel quite a lot
more british than dutch
and i keep up my dutch
i can fool most dutch people for five or
ten minutes
which is more than most dutch people
who've lived outside the country for so
long can do
and i'm rather proud of that and also
there are things to be learned
by learning from people of another
country as well as
euron did you ever remain in contact
with the non-jewish couple
or catharina who looked after you and
your sister
in the netherlands the family that
took my sister and i away from
the woman who looked after us in
terestadt
katarina kasuto de young
prevented further contact which broke
her heart and broke mine too
my sister was too young to really notice
in the 1980s i took a holiday to find
her again
and with the help of the netherlands red
cross i eventually succeeded
and we were reunited and met a number of
times and had loads of telephone
conversations
before she died of breast cancer her
husband unfortunately had already died
by the time i found her
the other woman who'd looked after me
whose name is very similar cartoon
it's another version of the name
catherine uh
whose husband had died in buchenwald con
in neuengamma concentration camp in
germany
uh for looking after me
uh again contact was essentially
prevented
and again i eventually found her again
and
reestablished contact and we had a
wonderful relationship during the last
years of her
life i used to go and visit her
in her old age home in amsterdam and we
had wonderful conversations and meals
out
and went to the botanical garden nearby
and her son born after
i was arrested and his wife are still
wonderful friends who i go and visit at
every opportunity
can there be a future without genocide
if we
had been sitting on this spot
three thousand years ago you might have
asked me can there be a future without
cannibalism
human sacrifice was normal we got rid of
it
if we can get rid of cannibalism why
can't we get rid of genocide
[Music]
the american psychologist stephen pinker
has written a book called the better
angels of our nature
and in that he provides
historical quantitative evidence
that the percentage of human beings
killed by
human beings has not increased
it has decreased millennium by
millennium
century by century even decade by decade
despite the horrors of the 20th and 21st
century
yes in absolute numbers more were killed
than in any historical period
because the world's population has
skyrocketed
but there is hope
the job i'm doing which is educating
young people about this kind of subject
can't be done unless one has hope and i
do but
professor stephen pinker has provided me
with academically justifiable reason
to bolster that hope and
he has radically changed my view
what advice would you give to young
people now to encourage them to create a
better future
reading writing arithmetic and the other
things people
learn in school primary school are no
longer sufficient
the human race in order to be able to
live with itself
without mass violence needs to learn
about itself in a way that has not
happened
up to now and that's
the responsibility of the younger
generation
adam and eve are youth board members for
holocaust memorial day trust
i think it's important to mark holocaust
memorial day because the
holocaust and the subsequent genocides
are really the most heinous and the most
important events which will probably
happen in human history
and to not learn from them to forget
about them
and to just cast them off into the past
is really a crime
in and of itself and i mean the
community securities trust and many
other bodies are showing us now that
we're having an increase in
anti-semitic crime hate crime as a whole
and
it would be just a disservice to all of
those who lost their lives
not to learn from their their history
and love from their past
and to forget about them the survivors
of
all of the genocides and the holocaust
aren't going to be around forever
so it's for us to be able to tell their
stories to future generations
for us to be able to learn from the
history of the past to be able to make a
better future to be able to
step away from hate crime and hopefully
roll back the clock
of what we've been seeing in recent
years i think it's really important to
mark holocaust memorial day
because i think it gives us a chance to
stop and to reflect on the past
and to the atrocities like the holocaust
that have happened in the past
but also because of the inclusion of
other genocides
like darfur which is an ongoing genocide
it makes us remember that the idea of
never again which is
attached to the holocaust a lot hasn't
actually been fully realized yet
and we need to keep pushing on and keep
educating more people so that more
people understand that genocide is still
part of the world today we can do more
to stop it
i think it's really important for young
people especially to mark
holocaust memorial day because they are
the future they're the future leaders
and the future people making decisions
so if they are involved and they're
interested
in learning about the past and what's
going on today and in wanting to change
it
i think that's really important before i
was a part of the holocaust memorial day
trust i really didn't know about other
genocides apart from the holocaust
so the education i got through being
part of the youth programs has really
pushed my life in a different direction
and opened my mind up to
hold different things that i didn't know
about before so i think it's really
really important find out more and sign
up to the hmdt youth programs at
hmd.org dot uk forward slash
youth
[Music]
so why the community and beyond
may we continue to remember well
and allow our remembering to transform
our lives
under the blessing of god almighty the
father the son
and the holy spirit be upon you
upon all those communities in which you
dwell
upon all your families now and
always
let us all today to commit to do
something no matter how
small to stand up against prejudice and
the processes of persecution
let's find out about where genocide is
taking place
those affected by it and tell others
what we learn
we will end with a moment of reflection
while we listen to the poem
the butterfly written by pavel friedman
whilst he was imprisoned in a
concentration camp
it is read by the actor samuel barnett
the last the very last
so richly brightly dazzlingly yellow
perhaps if the sun's tears would sing
against a white stone
such such a yellow is carried lightly
way up high it went away i'm
sure because it wished to kiss the world
goodbye
for seven weeks i've lived in here
penned up inside this ghetto
but i have found my people here
the dandelions called to me and the
white chestnut candles in the court
only i never saw another butterfly
that butterfly was the last one
butterflies don't live in here in the
ghetto